et puis les 12 pays de la communauté ont
approuvé formellement l'interdiction de
produits alimentaires en provenance de
l'est en liaison avec l'accident de
tchernobyl
en revanche pas d'accord sur une
harmonisation des normes de
radioactivité toléré dans les échanges
de produits frais entre les pays de la
communauté en france le ministre de
l'industrie monsieur madelin va
présenter demain la structure
interministérielle d'information sur
l'accident de tchernobyl
tandis que se poursuit dans notre pays
la polémique sur le manque
d'informations officielles dispensés
alors que le nuage radioactif a survolé
le territoire français jacques viau les
30 avril dépêche de l afp
monaco détecte le nuage dans notre
journal de 20 heures le directeur
adjoint du service de protection le fcpr
i n'est pas inquiet on pourra
certainement détecté dans quelques jours
le passage des particules mais où du
point de vue la santé publique il n'y a
aucun risque commentaires rassurants
mais on ne nous donne aucun chiffre
entre le 1er et le 4 mai aucun
communiqué officiel des pouvoirs publics
à ces dates le nuage évoluer gonfle sur
la france on jaunes et orangées sur ses
cartes sans information particulière
aucun média ne reparle de ce nuage cinq
minutes et pêche de l'efs et
déclarations du ministre de
l'agriculture les taux de radioactivité
des produits agricoles sont normaux en
feront de laboratoires d'analysés
confirme dans le journal de 20h vous
constaté aucune anomalie
dans le lait donc les normes n'ont pas
été dépassées n'ont pas été atteints
dans les 5 et 6 déclarations du
professeur pellerin lui et sepehri
disparition de la radioactivité en
france le nuage qui seulement la france
le 5 mai la radioactivité déposé sur le
sol reste 7 mais emmanuel vanier
interviews des gendarmes en alsace le
radiomètre est talonné sur les seuils de
sécurité aérienne enregistre au delà de
la catastrophe survenue à la centrale
ukrainienne le radiomètre vont et
équiper la brigade et que qui marche
puisque nous l'avons testé devant vous
n'a pas réagi donc il n'y a pas en
principe de radioactivité ambiante et
pourtant nous savons aujourd'hui que
l'alsace a été la région la plus touchée
par le nuage lui mais 19h premier
communiqué avec des chiffres expédié par
le professeur pellerin muette série à
notre rédaction pour la première fois la
radioactivité est évalué à 360 d'excel